her Exner sie sind Bäckermeister
Berlin-Brandenburg Süden BZ 37
Fachgeschäfte die und definitiv Teil der
arbeitenden Mitte in diesem Land haben
Sie das Gefühl dass ich ihre Arbeit
auszahlt
für mich persönlich immer weil ich ein
Handwerker bin liebe ich meine Arbeit
aber zur Zeit ist es so dass es sich
wieder finanziell auszahlt und auch
emotional ist es manchmal sehr schwierig
das sind sie noch bescheiden beim
Formulieren sie sind gerade auf der
Grünen
Woche denken sie dass auch die Bäcker
demonstrieren sollten sollten auch
Bäckermeister ein
Innungsobermeister sollte auch ein
Bäckermeister demonstrieren also
grundsätzlich sympathisiere ich mit den
Demonstration insbesondere der Bauern
für mich als bcker Meister ist es sehr
schwierig sag mal vielleicht mit meinen
Fahrzeugen dorthinzukommen wir müssen
tagtäglich arbeiten um Einkommen für
unsere mit Mitarbeiter zu generieren und
deswegen
herausfordernd aber die Bauern mit
frischen Brötchen zu füttern und dass
die da durchhalten da bin ich dafür ja
okay was geht ihnen gerade am meisten
auf die Nerven was ist am schlimmsten
wenn sie mal so auf ihre tägliche Woche
in auf die Woche gucken und auf ihre
Sorgen gucken
gibt viele Herausforderungen in unserer
Branche auch in der ganzen Gesellschaft
natürlich und ja viele Dinge sind ähm äh
schon seit langer Zeit ein dornem Auge
aber es wird halt immer herausfordernd
da Bürokratie ist ein großes Thema ähm
Personalmangel ist ein großes Thema aber
natürlich auch die explodierenden Kosten
in unserer Branche die uns haben 30
offene Stellen äh die sie ausschreiben
und die Kosten sind natürlich jetzt auch
wieder gestiegen die Mehrwertsteuer für
gastrosor wegfallen CO2 Preise steigen
all dieses was merken Sie darüber hinaus
am meisten rstofpreis die fehlenden
Mitarbeiter die wir suchen die brauchen
wir z.B dafür dass wir Fachgeschäfte
eröffnen und es ist teilweise so dass
wir am Nachmittag einige Fachgeschäfte
schließen müssen weil wir dieses
entsprechenden Personal nicht haben das
bedeutet der Umsatz an diesen Tagen
fehlt uns obwohl wir Miete zahlen und
auch die Logistikleistung haben und so
weiter das heißt uns fehlen Umsätze die
wir zur Deckung unserer Kosten brauchen
und welche Kosten sind am eklatantesten
gestiegen Personalkosten sind den
letzten vi Jahren möchte ich sagen aber
auch Rohstoffkosten z.B beisp Kilo
Zucker hat vor 4 Jahren noch 38 Cent
gekostet jetzt kostet 1,10 € und für
viele anderen Kollegen ist noch teurer
Energiekosten natürlich
2020 Vergleich zu 22 haben wir 700.000 €
mehr Energiekosten gehabt im Endeffekt
müss ich als Unternehmer sagen das zahlt
dann der Kunde aber diese
explosionsartigen Preise auf breiter
Front
kann ich als Unternehmer nicht mehr auf
den Kunden abwälzen der Markt gibt es
nicht her und deswegen ähm erzielen wir
keine Gewinne mehr keine Gewinne mehr
haben Sie das Gefühl dass diese Ampel
das verstanden hat diese Situation
verstanden hat die sich so addiert
aufadidiert äh ich persönlich habe nicht
den Eindruck dass die äh politisch
handelnden Personen überhaupt ich sag
mal so ansatzweise verstehen was da
passiert äh es gibt viel
Lippenbekenntnisse ja wir haben das
verstanden und so weiter aber ähm die
die Handlung die vollzogen werden diese
kurzfristigen Perspektivwechsel oder
ja gestern war der Fördertopf alle oder
was es da so für Themen gibt und so
weiter wir als Unternehmen brauchen
verlässliche Rahmenbedingung und die
bietet die derzeit die Politik nicht da
sind wir beim Thema und stellen fest
dass der streitmunter weitergeht obwohl
das in diesem Jahr 2024 unbedingt anders
werden sollte
R nichts geht mehr in Deutschland
Proteste Streiks und eine Regierung die
dasselbe versprechen vor zunehmend
leeren Rängen macht wir werden Hämmern
und Klopfen aber mit Schalldämpfer
pusterkuchen Minister zerpflücken die
eigene Regierungspolitik betteln um ein
bisschen
Zustimmung lasst uns diese Gelegenheit
nutzen dass diese sag mal unglücklichen
Beschlüsse der Bundesregierung was
Agrardiesel und KFZ angeht dass wir das
nach vorne gerichtet nutzen es ärgert
mich dass ich vor ihnen als den
fleißigen Mittelstand über Kürzungen
sprechen muss während auf der anderen
Seite in unserem Land Menschen Geld
bekommen fürs nichts tun und jetzt das
Kindergeld neues Jahr neuer Streit
Lindner kündigt einen höheren
Kinderfreibetrag an und schon geht's
wieder
rund nur Familien mit sehr hohen
Einkommen zu entlasten halte ich für
ungerecht sehr befremdlich findet dass
die FDP bei uns ist der fdpvorsitzende
und Bundesfinanzminister Christian
Lindner bleiben wir mal ganz kurz bei
diesem letzten weil jetzt streitet man
sich schon wieder intensiv über das
Kindergeld machen wir sofort der hat das
Kindergeld noch nicht thematisiert
insofern wollte ich ganz kurz darauf
abheben man kann das Kindergeld erhöhen
man kann diesen Freibetrag erhöhen man
kann es von beidem erhöhen man kann es
lassen aber warum kann man sich nicht
einigen in diese Regierung und das dann
einfach mal durchhalten das müssen sie
andere Fragen wir haben
2022 eine Entscheidung getroffen die ich
jetzt nur umsetze die Entscheidung ist
wir haben für die Jahre 23 und 24 das
Kindergeld so stark erhöht wie von 219
auf 250 so stark erhöht wie Jahrzehnte
nicht in einem einmaligen Schritt für
alle Kinder auf 250 € erhöht und wir
haben das mit dem Kinderfreibetrag bei
der Steuer nicht gemacht sondern den
ziehen wir jetzt nach das heißt sie
haben die eine große Erhöhung beim
Kindergeld auf 250 € sofort gemacht
damit alle profitieren können und unsere
Verfassung
ähm die äh fordert von uns dass wir das
Existenzminimum nicht besteuern weil es
ja nicht sein kann dass das was Menschen
brauchen um ihre Existenz zu bestreiten
dass sie das reduzieren müssen um an den
Staat Geld zu überweisen und das ziehen
wir jetzt nach das war der Beschluss des
Jahres 2022 bleiben Sie dass das
abgestimmt war mit dem Bundeskanzler das
glaube ich stellt auch der Bundeskanzler
nicht in Frage dass es so verabredet war
aber mir geht's äh vielleicht in dem
Zusammenhang dann doch auch noch mal um
ein gerechtigkeitsargument weil so ja
viele auch argumentieren ich möchte
darauf hinweisen dass wenn man für ein
Kind etwas für für 100 € äh kaufen
möchte ähm eine neue Jacke eine neue
Hose dann müssen Menschen mit einem
geringeren Einkommen ähm vor der Steuer
ich sage mal 120 € verdienen und dann
zahlen Sie Steuer und dann haben sie 100
€ für das Kind wer eine Fach oder
Führungskraft ist der muss sehr schnell
160 € vor dem Steuerrecht haben um die
gleichen 100 € für das Kind aufzuwenden
sie machen da noch mal diese
gerechtigkeits wir müssen sagen Menschen
die ein höheres Einkommen haben zahlen
eben auch prozentual höhere Steuer
deshal
7 untersch 377€ bekämen die Menschen die
eben den Freibetrag in Rechnung stellen
und beim Kindergeld wären es eben
259 um das auszugleichen die Frage ist
also€ 244 wäre eigentlich die Höhe des
Kindergelds aber ich sag es ist
überproportional erhöht worden aber ich
sage noch mal es geht ja darum dass die
Menschen die ein höheres Einkommen haben
auch prozentual mehr Steuern zahlen wir
sind sofort und da ist nämlich
unwunderbarerweise das Thema von Herrn
Exner die ganze Zeit auch angesprochen
wir sind bei Manuela Schwesig die wir
herzlich in Schwerin begrüßen die Chefin
von Mecklenburg vpoman also die
Ministerpräsidentin Frau schwiesig sie
sind SPD Politikerin das weiß
mittlerweile fast
jeder wenn es eigentlich eine
Verständigung gab zwischen dem
Bundesfinanzminister und Olaf Scholz
über diese Frage warum kann dann der
Bundeskanzler nicht dafür sorgen dass es
nicht 3 Minuten später von Lars
klingwall in Abrede gestellt wird warum
wird ständig
gestritten es ist nicht gut wenn die
Ampel ständig öffentlich streitet ich
sage aber ganz klar als
Ministerpräsidentin ein
auseinanderfallen zwischen
Kinderfreibetrag und Kindergeld gibt es
nicht und das gab es auch nicht als der
Bundesfinanzminister noch Schäuble war
und ich
Bundesfamilienministerin wir haben auch
sehr sehr viel diskutiert über Geld aber
immer hinter den Kulissen und wir waren
uns immer einig eine Verbesserung für
Familien muss es für alle Kinder geben
und wir reden ja hier gerade über die
arbeitende Mitte wir reden ja über die
Fachkräfte von unserem Bäckermeister
hier in der Runde das sind die Leute mit
kleinen und mittleren Einkommen und den
jetzt zu sagen für die
Spitzenverdiener wird der Freibetrag
erhöht aber für euch das Kindergeld
nicht weiter das ist ungerecht und das
darf es so auch nicht geben okay also
der Bürger versteht jetzt in dieser
Situation dieser Streit wird in der
Ampel weitergehen das heißt sie finden
richtig dass Lars klingb protestiert hat
obwohl es vorher eine Verständigung
offensichtlich darüber gegeben hat dass
diese überproportionale Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes begründet warum jetzt ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es diese
Verständigung gegeben hat weil es wäre
völlig neu und unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender der ja dabei war
bei der Runde der Fraktionsvorsitzenden
um als es ums Kindergeld ging hat ganz
klar gesagt dass es diese Verabredung
nicht gibt und noch mal ja das
Kindergeld ist an einem großen Schritt
erhöht worden das ist eine sehr gute
Leistung der Ampel will ich ausdrücklich
sagen weil es kostet viel Geld aber wir
haben die Familien dabei gut unterstützt
aber wir haben auch jedes Jahr den
Kinderfreibetrag erhöht und wenn er
jetzt wieder erhöht werden soll muss
auch das Kindergeld erhöht werden noch
mal über wen reden wir hier über die
Leute die arbeiten gehen jeden Tag K und
vielleicht ein paar mehr 100 € haben als
Bürgergeld genau die Leute die unsere
Handwerker und alle
suchen Kön nicht weniger Kinder hier
müssen wir mal aufklären wenn Sie sagen
die Menschen die etwas mehr als
Bürgergeld haben die erhalten nicht nur
das Kindergeld Frau Schwesig die
erhalten auch den Kinderzuschlag also
Menschen die arbeiten und ein sehr
geringes Einkommen haben erhalten zum
Kindergeld den Kinderzuschlag der ist
Anfang des Jahres um 42 € erhöht worden
das heißt diejenigen über die Frau
Schwesig spricht knapp über dem
Bürgergeld mit ihrem Arbeitseinkommen
die erht die erhalten proine nicht kN
über haben gerade gesagt erhalten pro
Kind 542 € und ich will noch mal sagen
wenn das Kindergeld sich genauso
entwickelt hätte wie der
Kinderfreibetrag dann würde das
Kindergeld in diesem Jahr 244 € betragen
es beträgt aber 250 und läs nä mich den
letzten Punkt sagen von wegen es war
nicht verabredet der Haushaltsausschuss
des Deutschen Bundestages hat in der
vergangenen Woche den Haushaltsentwurf
für dieses Jahr verabschiedet genau mit
dem Vorschlag Kinderfreibetrag zu
erhöhen sind bei sie müssen das
entschuldigen Frau Schwesig ich wandere
zu einem anderen Thema dahinter steckt
ein kleinerer oder größerer Gedanke wie
immer Sie wollen und wenn sich diese
Ampel dann mal einig ist wie bei den
Kürzungen für die Bauern dann melden
sich
Ministerpräsidenten und zwar vor allen
Dingen sozialdemokratische und
protestiert am besten ist natürlich wenn
der Vorschlag wieder ganz vom Tisch
genommen wird ich finde es aber wichtig
dass die Kürzung die angekündigten
Kürzung komplett zurückgenommen werden
die Sparvorschläge betreffen vor allem
den ländlichen Raum und das ist wirklich
falsch so das sagten sie und zwar sofort
nachdem das beschlossen war durch die
bundesspd den Bundeskanzler die Spitze
dieser Regierung was soll das Auslösen
bei den Leuten glauben Sie Frau elner
mir geht es um die Sache und als
Ministerpräsidentin vertrete ich die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger meines
Bundeslandes und nicht die Ampel und mit
Verlaub ich bin auch bei diesen
Gesprächen nicht dabei und wenn uns
vorher einer mal gefragt hätte und in
die Pläne einbezogen hätte dann hätten
wir auch klar gesagt dass es so nicht
geht und dass das schief geht fakt ist
dass die Sparpläne im jetzigen Haushalt
komplett den ländlichen Raum betreffen
einmal mit den Kürzung bei der
Landwirtschaft denen wir in den letzten
Monaten schon viele Sachen aufgelegt
haben dann mit der Rücknahme der
Unterstützung bei den Netzentgelten das
trifft vor allem bei mir viele die wo
die Windparks entstehen die jetzt höhere
Stromkosten haben werden was ja sowieso
absurd ist und der dritte Punkt die
Pendlerin und Pendler die jeden Tag zur
Arbeit fahren im ländlichen Raum haben
wir 6000 Dörfer da haben wir nicht
überall Bus und Bahn da ist das Auto
auch kein Luxusgut die pendeln die
stehen morgens auf und die Zahlen jetzt
mehr Spritkosten und wenn dann noch die
Ungerechtigkeit mit dem Kindergeld dazu
kommt das kann ich kein Bürger erklären
und wenn es ungerecht zugeht dann erhebe
ich meine Stimme das ist meine Aufgabe
so Herr Exner und dann denken sie dass
sie immer noch nicht wissen was jetzt in
beiden Fällen eigentlich rauskommt die
Bauern wissen es auch noch nicht es ist
noch nicht klar ob weiter verhandelt
wird oder ob dieser letzte Kompromiss
der Ampel jetzt tatsächlich dann der
Entscheidende ist dass also stufenweise
bei dem Agrardiesel diese Unterstützung
wegfällt würden sie auch sagen dass das
ihr allergrößtes Problem von allen ist
dass man nicht so richtig weiß was
morgen passiert das haben sie muniert
sie werden überfallen ähm erstens ist es
nicht ausgekocht und im Prinzip wird
jetzt so wo das Kind im Brunnen gefallen
hat wieder rumdiskutiert
es ist mir zu viel klein klein diese
Dinge die hier diskutiert werden das
sind 6 € mehr für das und 5 € mehr für
das äh es ist herscht gar keine Klarheit
also es ist keiner versteht das
mehr das können wir doch niemanden
erklären ja aber das doch ich kann ja
sie ich kann die Gelegenheit will ich ja
nutzt und es ist doch toll dass Exner
sie hier sind dann müssen wir die
Gelegenheit auch mal für ein Austausch
nutzen es wird in dem Bundeshaushalt
besteht der Plan den Bundeshaushalt den
wir jetzt vorgelegt haben worin besteht
der Plan den Bundeshaushalt den wir
jetzt vorgelegt haben das ist kein
kürzungshaushalt da wird nicht gespart
sondern wir verändern seine Struktur
damit wir neue Aufgaben finanzieren wir
haben mehr zu tun für unsere äußere
Sicherheit und die Friedens und
freiheitsordnung in
Europa lassen Sie mich do lassen Sie
mich doch ein Satz mal zu Ende
sprechen wir haben die Friedens und
freiheitsordnung in Europa die wir
verteidigen 15 Milliarden Euro entlasten
wir die arbeitende Mitte indem wir
nämlich Lohn und Einkommensteuer gesenkt
haben wir haben für Herrn Exner die
Stromsteuer reduziert auf das
europäische Minimum sie haben eben
gesagt sie zahlen 700.000 € zusätzliche
Energiekosten dann kalkuliere ich mal
dass sie viele viele Taus Euro in diesem
Jahr weniger Stromsteuer zahlen also das
ist ja das das was wir tun und wer auf
der einen Seite entlastet für exchner
tausende Euro weniger Stromsteuer für
die arbeitende Mitte weniger Lohnsteuer
der muss auf der anderen Seite dann auch
auf alte Subventionen verzichten wie
beispielsweise das Auslaufen des
agrardiesels und da reden wir über eine
Größenordnung im Jahr 2025 von 300
Millionen von 200 etwa 200 Millionen
Euro im Jahr 25 alleine die Stromsteuer
sind über 3 Milliarden Euro warum sind
wir auch so froh dass sie sich
eininander gegenübersetzt sie freuen
sich darüber dass sie äh tatsächlich
überall diese Steuern senken für die
Bürger aber es geht ja eben nicht nur um
Steuern sondern es werden an anderen
Stellen
Ausgleichszahlungen gebraucht vom Bürger
egal ob er Unternehmer oder Angestellter
was auch immer ist es kommt also ein
höherer Betrag am Ende heraus den man an
Ausgaben hat sie selber haben nein Herr
Exner wird sie Sel er sagt er macht
keinen Gewinn sie sie haben selber
gesagt vor 14 Tagen bei einer guten
tollen Kollegin der ARD
das ist einen tatsächlich einen
Wertverlust in diesem Land gibt einen
Wert und Vermögensverlust ja volkswircha
durch die Inflation durch die Kriege ich
kann das kurz
zusammenfassen wer sagt das und
akzeptiert das wir haben
volkswirtschaftlich einen Verlust an
Wohlstand weil wir mehr zahlen für die
Importe z.B für Energie das ist so und
die Lösung dafür ist dass wir insgesamt
eine stärker wachsende Wirtschaft haben
müssen dass wir wettbewerbsfähiger
werden und dennoch will ich schon sagen
dass wir gut durch die Krise mit den
energiepreisspitzen gekommen sind und es
gibt erhebliche Entlastung der Staat
kann ein insgesamt gesunkenes
Wohlstandsniveau aufgrund von Inflation
aufgrund der Kriege nicht auf Dauer
ausgleichen Staat kann ja der Staat kann
ja nur mit dem Geld umgehen dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihm zur Verfügung
stellen ist Limit sie sind stolz auf
ihre Steuersenkungen sie sind stolz
darauf dass sie steuern nicht erhöhen
müssen aber die Rechnung von Herrn Exner
war in anderen Jahren schon mal besser
da hatten sie natürlich haben wir auch
Geld verdient und auch gut Geld verdient
äh ich sag mal so ich glaube dass sie
aus ihrer Perspektive äh vielleicht
sagen ich habe bestimmte oder wir haben
bestimmte Dinge getan die das verbessert
haben aber ehrlich gesagt ich habe jetzt
gerade vor drei Tagen gelesen vor 12
Jahren gab es 4,5 Millionen Mitarbeiter
im öffentlichen Dienst und Beamte ja
jetzt nach 12 Jahren sind das 5
Millionen und ich frage mich wo die sind
ja wie viel zahlen die alle aber Lehrer
gibt's keine Polizisten gibt's keine
Staatsanwälte gibt's keine Richter
gibt's keine und so weiter äh was machen
denn diese ganzen Leute und ich verlange
vom stat dass er mit dem Geld auch gut
umgeht wie der stat das von den Bürgern
und von den Unternehmen auch verlangt
und ich glaube dass der Staat sich mal
limitieren muss in den Ausgaben ja
Explosionen ihr sie wissen selber wie
groß ihr Haushalt gestiegen ist in den
letzten paar Jahren wir haben wasiß ich
100 Milliarden mehr als vor dre oder
vier Jahren noch oder so und wir kommen
mit der Kohle nicht klar Herr Exner kann
ich ihn gern beantworten also der Bund
hat keine Millionen Beschäftigte der
Bund hat unter 300.000 Beschäftigte und
die Zahl ist gestiegen und wissen Sie wo
die sind Bundespolizei sind wir beide
der Meinung dass wir für die innere
Sicherheit mehr tun müssen ich glaube ja
Zoll dafür dass ein und Ausfuhr in
unserem
exportorientierten Land funktionieren
die zusätzlichen Beschäftigten sind z.B
beim Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge weil zumindestens ich der
Meinung schon ausgeführt die Frage war
ja wo können Sie sparen wo könen Sie
sparen ich der Meinung bin dass wir die
Asylverfahren beschleunigen müssen wo
können wir sparen ich habe z.B den
Neubau des Bundesfinanzministeriums
abgesagt wir können wir können sparen
auch wenn ich das mal offen ausspreche
bei der Treffsicherheit unseres
Sozialstaats deshalb haben wir
jetzt also wirklich bei jeder Antwort
unterbrechen Sie mich rede ich so lange
und rede ich so langweilig wir wir
müssen auch die Treffsicherheit unseres
Sozialstaats verbessern beispielsweise
sanktionieren jetzt die
bürgergeldempfänger die angebotene
Arbeit ablehnen die bekommen eine
Sanktion die bekommen kein Geld mehr und
die Punkte die Sie angesprochen haben
die sie wirtschaftlich bremsen sie haben
ja nicht zuerst von von Steuer oder
anderem gesprochen sie haben von
Bürokratie gesprochen eben ich bin ihrer
Meinung können wir einiges tun etwa bei
den ganzen Dokumentationen die es gibt
gerade im Bereich wo man mit
Lebensmitteln zu tun hat und zum anderen
sie haben gesagt ihnen fehlen
Arbeitskräfte und ich glaube eine
Möglichkeit besteht darin dass wir die
men Menschen die gegenwärtig dem
Arbeitsmarkt nicht zur Verfügung stehen
aktivieren beispielsweise bei den
geflüchteten aus der Ukraine machen wir
das durch mehr Kontaktdichte damit die
Menschen in Arbeit kommen und das ist
nichts Böses ich glaube dass Arbeit
nämlich auch dem Leben Sinn gibt dem
alltagstuktur und die Menschen das
Gefühl haben dazuugehören jetzt haben
sie ganz viele Sätze zu Ende gesprochen
und wir grüßen sehr herzlich Veronika
Grimm Ökonomen Wirtschaftsweise Frau
Grimm diese Kürzungen und es sind
Kürzungen da die da gibt's Argumente
dafür und es gibt immer Argumente
dagegen aber kann die Ampel den Protest
den es mittlerweile im Land gibt und den
es ja eben nicht mehr nur in einzelnen
Branchen gibt sondern bis zu den Ärzten
kann die Ampel das einfach ignorieren ne
ignorieren kann man es nicht man
reagiert ja auch drauf und passt dann
die Maßnahmen an aber ich glaube das
Problem ist schon evident es gab
Reallohn ähm die realen sind gesunken
aufgrund der Inflation Energiekosten
sind gestiegen es herrcht relativ viel
Druck im Land und äh natürlich braucht
es eigentlich einen Plan der den Leuten
sagt wir müssen Dinge anpacken wir
müssen uns auch verändern gleichzeitig
wollen wir Transformation hin zur
Klimaneutralität müss uns resilienter
machen das heißt es gibt eine ganze
Menge Aufgaben die doch ahnen lassen äh
dass es uns dauerhaft nicht so gut geht
oder dass wir einfach auch
Strukturwandel hinnehmen müssen und äh
ich glaube wenn man Strukturwandel
organisieren will der auch kommen wird
ihre Arbeitskosten werden teurer sie
werden auch mehr automatisieren äh
werden versuchen Arbeitskraft
einzusparen dadurch dass man
äh möch ich bin ja Handwerker will ich
ja nicht automatisieren in vielen
Bereichen geht das gut vielleicht sogar
besser als im Bäckerhandwerk und das
wird wiederum Arbeitskräfte freisetzen
da gibt es Prozesse die sind am Laufen
sozusagen viele Unternehmen planen zu
automatisieren entweder durch Roboter
oder auch durch
sof wird Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitnehmer
auch freisetzen und wird auch gegen die
Arbeitskräfte Knappheit entgegenwirken
aber ich glaube die Politik muss schon
einen umfassenderen Ansatz verfolgen
damit auch die Akzeptanz bei den
Menschen da ist weil die Menschen sind
schon auch z.B beim Klimaschutz sieht
man im Umfragen die Leute sind schon
bereit darauf auf ein bisschen was zu
verzichten aber eben nicht eine einzelne
Gruppe auf ganz viel ich glaube da muss
man schon einen ausgewogenen Plan machen
wo jeder sieht ich muss ein Stück weit
zurückstehen und was dafür geben dass
wir die Transformation schaffen aber
andere eben auch glaube das ist ganz
wichtig und letzter Satz vielleicht dazu
ich habe das Gefühl man verhagt sich da
auch deswegen einerseits weil der Druck
so stark ist und man dem Druck nachgibt
aber auf der anderen Seite auch weil in
der Ampel ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze
da sind wie man diese Transformation
schafft die einen wollen auf
Marktwirtschaft setzen sehr stark die
anderen eher auf Interventionen und
Hilfen und diese und und Subventionen
die beiden Ansätze passen nicht zusammen
und die Mitte von beiden so ein bisschen
von jedem das ist besonders schlecht
weil es die Leute verunsichert weil es
auch unberechenbar ist und ich glaube
das ist auch eins der Probleme mit dem
man sich einfach auseinandersetzen muss
okay Christiane Benner ist bei uns das
finden wir auch gut so sie ist die erste
Chefin Chefin Chefin der IG Metal
gewählt im letzten Oktober
2023 und sie haben das darf man verraten
auch ein SPD parteipunch wenn Sie auf
das Schauen Frau Benner was da gerade an
Politik angeboten wird ich sag's mal
ganz vorsichtig was ist ihr erster
Gedanke haben sie da den Gedanken äh da
gibt zwar drei unterschiedliche Parteien
aber die Arbeiten tatsächlich in eine
größere Richtung oder haben Sie das
Gefühl das sind drei sehr verschiedene
Parteien die sogar verschiedene Dinge
einen aber danach hat jeder wieder einen
anderen Plan ja
ähm ich habe mein mein SPD Parteibuch
übrigens mir angeschafft als es um eine
partnerschaftliche
Gleichstellungspolitik ging damals von
der SPD muss ich sagen das war für mich
der Auslöser also relativ spät relativ
spät ähm und ich möchte mich dem
anschließend was Frau Grimm auch gesagt
hat also ich glaube die Menschen
brauchen Zuversicht die Menschen
brauchen eine Idee und brauchen das
Gefühl dass die Regierung die jetzt am
Ruder ist dass sie weiß wie wir sicher
in diesem Land in die Zukunft steuern
und es ist einfach eine enorme
Verunsicherung und unsere Beschäftigten
in unseren und unsere Mitglieder
ich sag mal den fehlt schon
eine eine gute ich sag mal
Industriepolitik wo man wirklich sagt ja
wir haben enorme Herausforderung durch
Klimawandel durch Digitalisierung aber
wir haben eine Regierung die in die
Zukunft investiert und die die richtigen
Weichenstellung vornimmt wir haben eine
extrem kritische Phase im Moment also
ich behaupte in den nächsten zwei Jahren
werden ganz entscheidende Weichen
gestellt oder eben auch nicht die wenn
es gut gestellt wird wenn wir
Investitionen tätigen in unsere Zukunft
die dann auch dazu führen dass sie
erschwingliche Energiekosten haben bei
sich dann haben wir wirklich glaube ich
hier die Chance ja guter Leitmarkt zu
werden zu bleiben weiter Exportnation zu
bleiben weil wir alles können und das
ist gerade ein Problem und wenn jetzt
nichts passiert werden wir hier eine
Deindustrialisierung in Deutschland
erleben und unsere Beschäftigten haben
zum einen schon den Druck durch
Entscheidung wie was passiert jetzt
durch die CO2 freibepreisung mit meinen
Spritkosten mit meinen Energiekosten was
passiert mit meinen Möglichkeiten zu
Hause zu heizen wan muss ich da
umstellen wie viel Geld brauche ich
dafür kann ich mir ein elektrifiziertes
Fahrzeug leisten kann ich mir ein
E-Fahrzeug leisten es gibt echt
Unsicherheiten wenn dann aber in den
Betrieben noch dazu kommt dass da
Strategien fehlen oder unklar ist ob es
dieses Unternehmen noch geben wird ob
dieses Unternehmen erfolgreich durch
diese Transformation kommt dann wird es
echt schwierig und da arbeiten unsere
Betriebsräte und wir sehr se hart im
Moment auch an Alternativen und da
brauche ich aber auch eine entsprechende
Rahmung und ich plädiere massiv die
igemall pläiert massiv wirklich für
Investitionen in die Zukunft weil wir
eine Sondersituation haben sagt nicht
dass die nicht gekommen sind aber nicht
ausreichend und unsere starleute die
sind
veränderungsbereit die wollen die wollen
aber die Wissen sozusagen genau was
brauche ich dazu an Strukturen noch mal
an Unterstützung vom ST die haben wir
zum Teil auch bekommen aber wir müssen
wirklich auch gucken kriegen wir noch
mal mehr hin mit energieimport also es
braucht einfach eine die Kommunikation
einer Idee und einer Zuversicht ohne
Naivität und das fehlt unseren Leuten im
Moment und da sind die massiv
verunsichert und da
Arbeit einmal die Frage auch an die
kämpfende Gewerkschafterin jetzt ist
Beispiel Bauern die ampelregierung
gegenüber den Bauern eingeknickt und ist
ihnen entgegengekommen könnte man
freundlich sagen lohnt sich also der
Protest glauben sie oder übertreiben es
jetzt plötzlich alle in ihren Augen also
jetzt geht die GDL müssen wir nicht zu
konkret machen wer die geht als nächstes
die erzte gehen die Spediteure waren ähm
verhält die Ampel sich jetzt in dieser
Situation also ich meine unsere Leute
gehen ja auch auf die Straße bzw
warnstreiken wenn Sie eine berechtigte
Forderung durchsetzen wollen also wir
sind ja da durchaus kampfähig und sind
da durchaus äh konfliktbereit das machen
wir ja auch und ich sag mal ich meine
ich bin jetzt echt kein agrarexpertin ja
aber ich kann doch nicht den Diesel so
verteuern und ich meine ich habe ja
keine elektrifizierten Traktoren also
ich glaube wir müssen grundsätzlich mal
gucken wie gestalten wir für Menschen
die Übergänge und das muss ich plausibel
kommunizieren und dann nach Möglichkeit
auch nicht überrascht werden es ist ein
kommunikatives Thema aber es ist auch
ein inhaltliches Thema und ich sag mal
Geld noch mal mit dem Thema ich kann
irgendwie nur ausgeben was ich einnehme
ich könnte aber auch mal umverteilen mit
einer anderen Steuerpolitik F ich auch
cool das heißt die Bauern die Bauern
zahlen dann eine höhere Einkommen Steuer
damit sie auf der anderen Seite eine
Subvention bekommen nein ich will sagen
es wurde ja nicht wirklich gut
priorisiert es wurde einfach gestrichen
dann wurden Leute damit überrascht und
es wird darauf zurückgeführt dass wir
logischerweise aufgrund des
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteils anders
Haushalten mussten mit dem
klimatransformation gar keinr vlag
steuererhung mein konkreter Vorschlag
ist dass wir die sehr gut verdienenden
in diesem Land dass wir die anders zur
Kasse bitten sag ich ganz ehrlich weil
es gibt ein Gefühl der
Ungerechtigkeit und da haben wir auch
das Thema am Anfang gehabt mit dem
Kindergeld es ist einfach das Gefühl
dass man fragt warum bekommen die den
sowieso recht gut geht warum bekommen
die dann einen anderen Freibetrag warum
bekomme ich Herr Lindner warum
profitiere ich jetzt von ihrer neuen
Einkommensteuer ganz ehrlich ich habe es
nicht nötig sie auch nicht warum können
wir das nicht so machen dass die
Menschen mit niedrigen Einkommen dass
die überproportional von einer
steuerveränderung profitierenag
Existenzminimum muss immer steuerfrei
sein und da sie mit ihrem hohen
Einkommen oder ich oder Frau
ner da wir prozentual mehr Steuern
zahlen also Frau ilner vielleicht
45% wirkt ein Betrag den sie nicht
versteuern muss natürlich für Sie in
Euro und Cent höher als Menschen die ein
geringeres zu versteuernes Einkommen
haben aber das ist eben Verfassungsrecht
wir können es nicht ändern den Vorschlag
allgemein die Steuern zu erhöhen ich
kann nur abraten nicht allgemein ja sie
haben gesagt bei denen die über höhere
Einkommen verfügen ich kann deshalb
abraten davon weil wir ja gerade in
einer schwierigen konjunkturellen
Situation sind wir haben wenig Wachstum
wir wollen das auch die Betriebe
investieren und sehr viele
Handwerksbetriebe ich weiß nicht her
Exner ob das in Ihrem Fall so ist das
sind
Personengesellschaften für die ist also
die Einkommenssteuer zugleich auch die
betriebliche Steuer das ist unser
Mittelstand und ich kann in der jetzigen
wirtschaftlichen Situation nur abraten
von Steuererhöhungen wir können an
anderen stellenmittel gewinnen im
Haushalt gibt es Spielräume glaube dass
wir beim Bereich
Bürokratie die Wirtschaft beleben können
in dem wir Lasten
reduzieren wir können an anderen Stellen
auch über Subventionen sprechen tut
immer weh ist immer eine kritische
Diskussion Steuern erhöhen ich rate ab
so wir braen noch mal zurück
entschuldigung wenn ich da noch mal
einen Blick zurückwage wir gucken uns
vielleicht noch mal an was der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz Ende November
nachdem es dieses
Bundesverfassungsgericht Urteil gegeben
hat und also mal rasch 60 Milliarden
Euro fehlt was er da gesagt hat im
Deutschen Bundestag in ihrem Alltag hier
und heute ändert das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgericht nichts völlig
unabhängig davon ob sie Kindergeld oder
barfk bekommen eine Rente oder
Wohngeld wir sind Herr Lindner bei genau
der Frage warum sagt der Kanzler so
etwas macht er das weil er befürchtet
dass am nächsten Tag dann alle Menschen
auf der Straße sind oder ist er
überzeugt davon dass die Leute das nicht
merken würden natürlich merken Sie sie
wenn 60 Milliarden Euro fehlen oder ja
aber die 60 Milliarden Euro sind ja wenn
wir schon so präzise sprechen im Klima
und transformationsfond gelandet das ja
dort sind sie ausgebucht worden stehen
sie nicht zur Verfügung das ist Geld das
eingesetzt worden ist z.B für die
Finanzierung der Unterstützung für die
Stahlindustrie dafür sind diese Dinge
eingesetzt worden aber wenn Sie jetzt
den Einspieler von Herrn Scholz nehmen
das barfük ist nicht gekürzt worden das
Wohngeld ist nicht gekürzt worden die
Renten sind nicht gekürzt worden sondern
im Gegenteil wir haben zum 1. dieses
Jahres 15 Milliarden Euro weniger Lohn
und einkommenenssteuer ich sprach von
der stromsteuersenkung sie sprachen von
der stromsteuersenkung die jetzt ja
durch die netzentgeld nicht mehr Zahlung
nicht mehr subventionieren also das muss
ich ihnen nicht erzählen ich denke sie
wissen es eigentlich net Netzentgelte
sind subventioniert worden mit 5,5
Milliarden und müsen die BGer und die
industri zah ja es wäre aber ohnehin nur
für das erste Halbjahr 2000 24 gewesen
war ohnehin nur dafür geplant wir müssen
eine Sache will ich ganz sie haben es ja
eben auch über die Gastronomie
gesprochen wir haben während der
Pandemie und dann auch während der des
energiepreisschockses nach dem dem
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine gab es
Krisenmaßnahmen vor der Pandemie hatten
wir 19% bei der Speisegastronomie die
haben wir jetzt auch wieder und viele
haben sich natürlich gewöhnt an die
Krisenmaßnahmen des Staats sind auf
Dauer aber nicht finanzierbar ich bin da
der Überbringer der unglücksbotschaft
aber wir müssen einfach als Erwachsene
der Realität ins Auge schauen der Staat
arbeitet mit dem Geld der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger er kann sich partiell mal
Geld leihen aber er kann nicht auf Dauer
auf Pump die Wirtschaft in Gang halten
das können die Menschen selbst Z es ist
ja der zweite wichtige Satz zu sagen
dass das erstens nicht alles kompensiert
werden konnte was verloren gegangen ist
durch Krieg und Inflation und dass man
tatsächlich wenn dann auch noch 60
Milliarden zusätzlich fehlen weil ein
Haushaltsverfahren nicht anerkannt wird
durch das höchste deutsche Gericht dann
ist das natürlich noch mal eine
Verschärfung der Situation Frau Schwesig
was würden Sie sagen ist in den Augen
der Bürger am
eklatantesten dass man nicht sagt es
wird Einschnitte geben oder dass es
irgendwie ständig mit diesen Lösungen
hin und her geht was ist dramatischer in
ihren Augen den Bürgern fehlt die lange
und die
Planungssicherheit durch das Urteil ist
es jetzt eben so gewesen dass die
bundesregion kurzfristig handeln musste
das muss man ihr zugestehen aber dann
kam eben die Entscheidung über Nacht und
noch mal um über die Landwirte zu
sprechen die haben dann eben sind
morgens aufgewacht und haben gehört es
werden zwei wichtige
Unterstützungsleistungen gestrichen
nachdem wir ja gerade in den letzten
Jahren den Landwirten einiges zugemutet
haben wir verlangen von ihnen jedes Jahr
einen gewissen Anteil ihrer Fläche still
zu legen und damit immer 4% pro Jahr und
damit auf Erträge zu verzichten wir
setzen gerade mit der düngerverordnung
strenge Regeln zum Düngen um was weniger
Erträge bedeutet die Landwirte sind sehr
solidarisch was die Ukraine angeht wir
haben z oder lassen zu dass die
ukrainischen Bauern ihr Getreide auf dem
europäischen Markt verkaufen können und
das bedeutet aber für unsere Landwirte
nicht die Erträge zu erzählen wie sonst
weil sie ja viel teurer produzieren mit
Mindestlohn mit tariflohner und anderen
Vorgaben die wir für Umweltschutz machen
und jetzt packen wir auf alleine die
drei Maßnahmen es gibt noch mehr packt
denn man auf einmal eine Belastung durch
Kfz-Steuer rauf und Kürzung Agrardiesel
und das über Nacht ohne dass man es
vorher besprochen hat da dass das ist z
fast zum Überlaufen bringt ist auch klar
und dann ist es gut dass die
Bundesregierung eigentlich reagiert hat
und da will würde ich nicht von Umfallen
reden ich finde dieses Wort gefährlich
weil es immer dazu führt dass kein
Politiker sich traut äh oh dann heißt es
ja ich bin umgefallen eine falsche
Entscheidung zurückzunehmen ich finde
das richtig wenn man erkennt das ist
falsch nur der neue Kompromiss ist ja
auch nicht besprochen worden mit den
Bauern und dieses über Nacht
entscheiden über die Köpf hin weg und
nicht miteinander reden das ist
eigentlich das was auch äh neben dem
konkreten materiellen eben auch zur Wut
führt mhm wir sind bei einem zweiten
Punkt den Herr Lindner aufgemacht hat
und Herr Exner auch und den wollen wir
auf gar keinen Fall nicht besprechen
nämlich der Diskussion um das Bürgergeld
weil sie zurecht sagen dass es schwierig
ist Arbeitskräfte zu finden an diesem
Markt und vielleicht eben auch ihre
Arbeitskräfte zu halten das werden Sie
uns gleich erzählen jemand der arbeitet
verdient mehr logischerweise mehr als
ein Bürger Geldempfänger also als jemand
der die Unterstützung der Gemeinschaft
des Staates in Anspruch nimmt
sieht das mit dem Bürgergeld auch noch
ein fleißiger Geselle so in ihrer Firma
der morgens sehr früh morgens in in den
bäckerbetrieb kommt wie wird es
diskutiert bei Ihnen also erstens meine
Meinung ist dass die äh sozialen
Systeme ausgenutzt werden und für mich
ist es so dass die sozialen Systeme
dafür da sind Leute zu unterstützen die
in Not sind und die Unterstützung der
Allgemeinheit benötigen mhm wenn ich
aber weiß dass ich sag mal 5 Millionen
Leute diese an diese Leistung in
Anspruch nehmen aber auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt sehr viele Millionen
Arbeitsplätze nicht besetzt sind dann
ist das ein Missverhältnis was ich nicht
gut heißen kann und dann ist es aus
meiner Sicht so attraktiv nicht zu
arbeiten und das manestiert sich darin
dass dann im Prinzip zu mir z.B ein
Mitarbeiter kommt und sagt her Exner
kündigen Sie mich
bitte ich das lohnt sich hier nicht mehr
für mich 10 Jahre da 20 Jahre da und ja
Auto ist kaputt gegangen und wenn ich
mir jetzt ein neues kaufe das das lohnt
sich einfach nicht für mich habe mir das
mal
ausgerechnet da bleib ich lieber zu
Hause betreue meine Kind oder sowas in
der Richtung Speich das Geld für die
Kita
und natürlich weiß ich nicht wie das
Missverhältnis ist aber ich sag mal das
sind vielleicht 200 € 300 400 500 € die
dit bei mir bei mir mehr bekommt obwohl
ich tariflöne zahle oder
mehr nur ist es so dass man dann die
Wohnung bezahlt bekommt und viele andere
Leistungen Geld dazu und viele andere
Leistungen die man noch dazu bekommen
kann und ich bin der Meinung dass
derjenige der bei mir arbeitet der das
ja bezahlt für
dass der viel weniger dafür leisten
sollte also meine Meinung wir können mal
darüber reden ich finde das nicht gut
dass wir nur 11 700 €
einkommenenssteuergrenze haben sondern
die sollten das auf 24 000 €
hochschrauben 2000 € Monat sind
steuerfrei für meine Mitarbeiter warum
ich finde diese ganzen Transferleistung
furchtbar dass meine Mitarbeiter zum
Teil betteln müssen bei den Behörden
sagen hier ich gehe zwar arbeiten aber
ich mir steht das und das zu jetzt muss
ich ein Antrag ausfen den ich nicht
verstehe dafür müssen wieder Behörden
ich sag mal gefüttert werden viele Leute
arbeiten da und da sind viele
bürokratische Prozesse die eigentlich
gar nicht notwendig sind und ich finde
unsere Mitarbeiter müssen von ihren
Einkommen leben können und jetzt kann
jemand davon den Politiken politischen
Verantwortlichen kommen sagt wir sollen
ja mehr bezahlen ja das geht aber nicht
weil wir das nicht erwirtschaften mhm
Herr Lindner ja wir müssen unseren
sozial ja wir müssen unseren Sozialstaat
ähm ein reformieren
revolutionierenäh
prüfen wo es solche Fehlanreize gibt
will ich sagen ich höre das was Herr
Exner sagt nicht zum ersten Mal das wird
sehr oft an mich herangetragen wir haben
inzwischen einen Sozialstaat der sehr
kompliziert geworden ist GI sehr viele
unterschiedliche Leistungen wir haben
schon gesprochen über das Kindergeld
Kinderzuschlag
kindersofortzuschlag
Kindergrundsicherung cheld und es muss
ja ganz klar sein ich GLB da stimmen wir
alle überein wenn Menschen ein
Schicksalsschlag haben verschuet in Not
geraten dann ja wenn Sie erkrankt sind
dann sind wir solidarisch aber
Solidarität ist eben keine Einbahnstraße
man kann erwarten dass Menschen die
Solidarität der Gesellschaft nur so
lange in Anspruch nehmen wie sie sie
wirklich brauchen konkret jetzt beim
Bürgergeld wir haben die Situation dass
der Regelsatz zum 1 sehr stark gestiegen
ist ich sage offen er ist
überproportional stark gestiegen denn
als er festgelegt worden ist ist man von
einer ganz anderen Inflationsrate für
den Januar 2024 ausgegangen das ist da
eingeflossen und deshalb gab es die
überproportionale Erhöhung so wollen wir
ganz kurz mal die Konsequenz wird sein
das will ich nur den Einsatz ergänzen
Konsequenz wird nach meiner Erwartung
sein dass zum
1.1.2025 es eine Nullrunde beim
Bürgergeld geben wird um die
überproportionale Erhöhung wieder
einzuarbeiten das ist dann schon eine
Ankündigung Frau Benner wir verstehen
wenn wir die Gewerkschafterin äh jetzt
dazu mal hören haben Sie das Gefühl dass
sich diese Regierung um ihre Fachkräfte
um ihre Facharbeiter hinlänglich genug
kümmert oder kümmert sie sich mehr um
die Rentner und Leistungsempfänger wie
sieht es aus ihrer Warte aus also
Rentner und Leistungsempfänger sind zwei
verschiedene Paar Schuh Rentner haben
nämlich was gearbeitet für die R
richtig hier ist für uns wäre das ein
ganz ganz wichtiger Beitrag wenn wir das
was wir jetzt auf den Weg gebracht haben
was auch im Koalitionsvertrag steht
nämlich das tun hier in diesem Land um
Tarifbindung zu stärken wenn wir da
einen Schritt weitergehen wir haben
einfach da ein Problem und ich glaube
dieses auseinander drifft ich sag mal
wenn man jetzt sagt bürgergeldempfänger
mindestlohnempfänger Menschen die in der
freien Wirtschaft arbeiten dass da
sozusagen diese Proportion stimm da
könnte Tarifbindung könnte ein ganz
wichtigen Anreiz bieten und sie sind ja
auch soweit ich weiß Tarif gebunden das
heißt an der Stelle und ich finde es
gehört auch da
erhe undfühl von Gerechtigkeit wir
erkämpfen das schon selbst ich erwarte
von keinem Arbeitgeber dass der uns
irgendwie ein fertigen Tarifvertrag auf
den Tisch lägt aber das noch mal
anzugehen und zu sagen wie können wir da
auch dafür sorgen dass Menschen da
Gerechtigkeit empfinden und es wäre für
unsere Mitglieder wäre das das definitiv
ein vor wirklich ein richtiger
fortschrittil ihre Leute wahrscheinlich
auch auf der Zinne waren Frau Schwesig
die Frage muss unbedingt nach schwer
Gestell wer die SPD war Hubert he Ende
November voll des Lobes das Bürgergeld
ist die größte sozialstaatsrefum seit 20
Jahren zwei Monate später hörte sich das
dezidiert anders an jetzt wird den
Empfängern
gedroht wer aber nicht mitzieht und sich
allen Angeboten verweigert muss mit
härteren Konsequenzen
rechnen mit konsequenten Sanktionen
gegen totalweiger
schaffen wir mehr Gerechtigkeit im
Sozialstaat total Verweigerer und weil
die SPD das also jetzt gemerkt hat dass
es da einen zu kleinen Sprung gibt
schimpft sie mit der FDP zusammen auf
die nichtsur und
Totalverweigerer ich finde es gibt zwei
Prinzipien die in Deutschland wichtig
sind für die Akzeptanz erstens Arbeit
muss ich lohnen wer arbeitet muss
definitiv definitiv mehr haben deutlich
mehr haben als der der nicht arbeitet
und das geht über gute Löhne der zweite
Punkt ähm dass wir es auch wichtig ist
für den Sozialstaat wir sind auch ein
Sozialstaat dass Menschen in Not
unterstützt werden und da gibt auch das
Verfassungsgericht ganz klare Vorgaben
wie so ein Existenzminimum dieses
Bürgergeld zu berechnen ist und ich fand
sehr gut die ursprüngliche Idee im
Bürgergeld zu sagen und wer in diesem
Bürgergeld sich anstrengt und wer was
mit also wer Weiterbildung macht und und
und der hat eigentlich ich sag mal ein
bisschen mehr Bürger Geld das ist ja
jetzt leider kommt ja leider aus
Geldgründen nicht was aber kein
Widerspruch ist dass unser
Arbeitsminister sagt und wer dieses
System ausnutzt sich total verweigert
auch es sind nur ganz ganz wenige wir
müssen immer dran denken es gibt ganz
viele Menschen in unserem Land die auf
Bürgergeld angewiesen sind leider auch
Leute die sogar arbeiten weil sie so
wenig bekommen oder auch Rentner über
die Grundsicherung aber wenn es auch nur
einzelne sind die das System nutzen dann
ist es auch richtig Konsequenzen zu
ziehen deswegen ist es für mich kein
Widerspruch ich will auch nicht nur auf
den Bund schauen sondern sagen was auch
Länder machen können ebend hat der Exner
ein Beispiel gemacht wir haben die
Möglichkeit in Deutschland dass alle
Kinder wo Eltern Sozialleistung bekommen
wie Bürgergeld kostenfrei in die Kita
können das finde ich auch wichtig das
eine Bildungseinrichtung und alle Kinder
sollten den Zugang haben aber die Eltern
die Arbeiten gehen die müssen in der
Regel kitgebühren bezahlen so war das
auch bei uns im Land bis vor kurzen
kurzen und diese Ungerechtigkeit haben
wir die Arbeitenden Mütter und Väter
immer gesagt und einem das vorgerechnet
und deswegen haben wir die Kita Gebühren
komplett abgeschafft in Krippe
Kindergarten Hort jetzt auch im
ferienhort weil es ja die Leute in der
Dienstleistung sind im Krankenhaus die
in Ferien arbeiten um eine Gerechtigkeit
zu Gerechtigkeitslücke die
ungerechtigkeitslücke die da ne
Gerechtigkeitslücke sorry die D war zu
schließen und das ist auch etwas was
unser Beitrag ist so und dann sind wir
Herr Lindner wieder bei der Frage und
weil sie die Mittelschicht also nicht
weiter entlen können ist auch der
Finanzminister mit diesem Satz zu
zitieren mit dem wir die Sendung
begonnen von den
bauernprotesten wo sie
vor den nichtsturen warnen will ich
jetzt nicht sagen aber wo sie die
nichtstur deklassifizieren wollten also
mus was heiß was heißt deklassifizieren
das ist eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit es
gibt nicht die Wahlfreiheit ob ich
Sozialleistungen beziehe oder ob ich
arbeiten gehe und wenn wir die Situation
sehen es gibt Menschen die haben ein
tarifeinkommen ähm und ist vi ist
vielleicht ist vielleicht eine
Partnerschaft wo nur einer arbeitet da
sind Kinder in der Familie die Miete
wird übernommen und dann muss man schon
viele Taus Euro netto haben dass man
durch Arbeit mehr hat als der
sozialleistungsanspruch ist muss ja nur
mal schauen wie sind die Mieten in
München für die einen übernimmt der
Staat und für die anderen die Zahlen
selber und da gibt's keine Wahlfreiheit
und insofern nur der der sich leisten
kann kann zu Hause bleiben und sagen ich
tu nicht nein ist unsere muss muss nein
meine Konsequenz ist ähm es geht nicht
nur um die Totalverweigerer es muss sich
für alle lohnen dass sie arbeiten und
bei denen die nicht arbeiten muss man
teilweise auch die Kontaktdichte erhöhen
dann muss dann die Arbeitsagentur öfter
verlangen dass die Menschen vorstellig
werden da müssen Angebote gemacht werden
weil ich sage noch mal es gibt nicht die
Wahlfreiheit ob ich arbeite oder
Sozialleistungen beziehe es ist keine
Rente die man erworben hat sondern da
steht eine Leistung dahinter die SPD hat
dann ein ziemlichen move gemacht Frau
Grimm 170 Millionen wird das ungefähr
bringen sagen Schätzungen werden wir
damit unser arbeitsmarktproblem lösen ja
unser arbeitsmarktproblem lösen wir
damit nicht aber es ist erstmal ganz
wichtig glaube ich dass man klar macht
man ist schon in der Pflicht
zumutbare Arbeit anzunehmen es ist auch
wichtig diejenigen die im Transfersystem
sind zu motivieren zu arbeiten auch in
die Richtung gibt es ja Bemühungen dass
man die transferentzugsraten
reduziert dass man also mehr davon hat
ich erklärre es gerade dass man mehr
davon hat wenn man arbeitet also mehr
einbehalten darf das klingt erstmal so
als ob es mehr kostet tut es aber nicht
weil dadurch wird Arbeiten attraktiver
und die Menschen kommen dann eher aus
dem Transfersystem raus und ich glaube
das ist schon wichtig man muss den
Menschen schon klar machen ihr seid
aufgefangen wenn ihr nicht könnt aber
ihr seid auch in der Pflicht zu arbeiten
wenn ihr könnt was schwierig ist wurde
auch schon angesprochen das System ist
extrem komplex man versteht teilweise
auch gar nicht wo man jetzt besser da
steht man hat macht dauernd Diskussionen
auf über Umverteilungen anderen
Bereichen im
Rentensystem beim klimageld überall will
man auch noch on top umverteilen und das
führt natürlich dazu dass die Leute auch
verwirt sind dass sie gar nicht mehr
wissen wann stehe ich denn wie besser da
also ich glaube es wäre schon sehr
wichtig dass wir sehen das gerade an der
an dem Beispiel der Ukrainer Christian
Linder sprach das auch an 17% gelingt
schaffen wir den arbeitsmark aber ich
glaube es wä wichtig den Menschen klar
zumachen es gibt das System das euch
aufhängt aber es ist auch klar sozusagen
es gibt ein klares System klares
Koordinatensystem darüber hinaus man
versucht jer stelle man sich fallen
lässt sonder es sollte ein Trampolin
sein dass im Fall des Schicksalsschlags
die Menschen zurück in den arbeitsm auch
Möglichkeiten gibt auch
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeit schon auch
muss man ja sagen
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten werden eben
auch viel viel wichtig auch zwischen den
verschiedenen Branchen und den
verschiedenen Betrieben hinweg hier
brauchen wir wirklich auch
aktiv noch mal einen Punkt sagen sind ja
viele
bürgergeldempfängerinnen muss man s sind
viele Frauen sind Alleinerziehende denen
dann wiederum kitterplatz fehlt also ich
will jetzt hier nicht eine komplette
Lanze brechen und sagen D können alle
irgendwie nichts dafür aber man muss
sich das mal anschauen der die Zahl ist
so nach oben gegangen auch durch die
ganzen Empfänger und empfängerinen aus
der Ukraine weil die das sofort bekommen
haben also ich würde mal so ein bisschen
das relativieren und das Thema ist schon
auch politisch muss ich echt mal sagen
auch hochgezogen worden weil ich meine
es gab ja auch vorher ein Bürgergeld da
war das weniger ein Thema sondern es gab
ein Konsens in unserem Sozialstaat das
Thema ist schon ich sag mal das ist
richtig hochgekocht und wenn man jetzt
ab S zwei Seiten Vau BenMan hat sich
offensichtlich in der Regierung
beeindrucken lassen sonst Ex W die
Reaktion ja
nicht zwei Monate später man beobachtet
es aber auch nicht dass aus der
Berufstätigkeit viele jetzt ins
Bürgergeld ganz genau das sieht man in
den Daten so nicht das muss man auch
sagen aber trotzdem muss die Disk wir
sind immer noch bei unserem Titel wir
wollen her Exner wir alle verstehen
warum ist ausgerechnet diese fleißige
Mittel warum ist die so unzufrieden mit
ihrer
Situation die Frage ist vielleicht
müsste man einfach eine andere Politik
machen drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der
Welt das klingt nach Reichtum nur der
ist ungleich
verteilt die oberen 10% der deutschen
Haushalte verfügen über mindestens
725.000 €
Vermögen die unteren 40% maximal über 44
000 € das mittlere Vermögen beträgt
€. somit liegen die deutschen gerade mal
knapp vor den Griechen aber hinter den
meisten anderen
Europäern das mittlere Vermögen in der
Eurozone beträgt
150.000 €. die arbeitende Mitte hat
keine
Reserven Herr Lindner sie kennen unter
Garantie diese OECD Studie wir sind da
kurz hinter Griechenland erklären kann
man das kurz damit dass auch das
Immobilienvermögen ganz gering ist in
Deutschland wir sind ein Volk der Mieter
das mal in Klammern gesetzt was Ökonomen
kritisieren auch internationale Ökonomen
ist dass wir den Lohn sehr belasten aber
mögen und Erben eben viel weniger
belasten und das könnte der Grund dafür
sein warum Menschen das Gefühl haben
dass man allein mit richtig fleißiger
Arbeit nicht mehr reich werden kann in
diesem Land also ich glaube wenn sie auf
ein zeigen mit 30 Filialen schätze ich
schon dass 37 dass er dann eher auch zu
den oberen 10% gehört um g sie leider
falsch um ganz vorsichtig zu sagen sie
gleich fr ganz vorsichtig zu sagen aber
tatsächlich ist es so dass das Vermögen
in Deutschland ja unser Mittelstand ist
das sind unsere Familienbetriebe die wir
haben und natürlich kann man jetzt eine
Diskussion darüber führen wollen wir
eine Vermögenssteuer einführen wollen
wir die abschaftsteuer erhöhen die
Diskussion können wir führen ich will
nur auf die Konsequenz aufmerksam machen
das sind nicht in Deutschland vor allen
Dingen willenbesitzer jachtenbesitzer
Leute die
Gemälde haben oder anderes sondern das
ist in der Regel die Substanz unseres
Unternehmen tätigen Mittelstands da wird
dann besteuert
die Gebäude
das geistige Eigentum der Maschinenpark
der Fuhrpark und da verlieren wir mehr
als wir gewinnen denn wir wollen doch
dass diese Betriebe jetzt in der
Transformation auf Richtung
Klimaneutralität dass die investieren
dass in der Krise Arbeitskräfte erhalten
alles auch fleißige Menschen wir kommen
noch mal zu der strukturellen Frage